lift you can do it i have it in a minute
because there's the gyms aren't open
right i miss it i miss well i give you
kettlebells on the jump rope and stuff
kettlebell yeah in the jump rope but i
mean i hate when people say the gyms
aren't open
yeah i know that yeah the gym we already
yeah how about you left the 260 pounds
yeah you be quiet you're on the same
[ __ ] yeah
i'll listen to you what no i'm 255. okay
so you're recognizing brian ryan
what no i'm saying look awesome
you know i'm a freak athlete i know i'm
your business yeah he's my biggest fan
oh you're the best
yeah here's the thing you're the best
you're the best hey
hold on you're built like jerome battis
and it's [ __ ] fun
bring up the bus bring up the bus you
would have been
you could have been a hell of a running
back you would have been you had to run
right through that was a great
cheerleader they would have you built
like jerome bettis there he is yeah
that guy's a running back it's not
there's nothing to be mad about look at
him big boy
they call him the bus and he's a running
back he left one of the
100 that's you by the way that's a great
question first of all
you're the best you're the boss his legs
are way bigger than mine
well he's in shape you got some big legs
you were i was watching you carrying
dumbbells with no problem yeah you were
like dude
like it was a lunch box oh yeah we
worked out with kevin yeah yeah phoenix
because uh he doubted me that i could
carry a hundred pound dumbbells
you didn't no biggest fan no you're very
strong you're now
you're not shop now now i i didn't say i
was they're strong
we know this there's he's got a weird
thing going on he's got that
he's got that bear strength for real but
you're very strong
thank you you're very strong you're
probably more explosive than brendan
so if you really trained i think you
might get him on squats
yeah he's he's built for squats yeah
yeah yeah but i'm not dead lift i don't
know if you're getting them
at 40. i don't know if you're getting
them on deadlift and i don't think
you're getting it what do you get
deadlift
what about well his name and number his
brother oh my gosh
you destroy that can i i'd do that right
you know
4 15. educate him he'll do it he'll do
it you wake him up from a nap
wake him up from a nap
well well i watched him while i watched
him i watched him
i watched him take 550 and i watched him
do 10 sets
i watched him do 10 reps and they did 10
sets of 10 reps
now hold on hold on he did he did 550.
100 times opponent times haunted times
okay now now i said to his brother i
said now jay's no wheeling either j.j is
jay goes if you put a 500 pound on the
floor right now i'll lift him right now
you're eating lunch and he goes he get
that's when he gets he gets all kinds of
fed
yeah i'll lift 500 pounds he pointed the
ground to an imaginary okay
straight bar but he said that brennan
when brendan was lifting when he was
deadlifting when he was really when he's
playing football
the gym owner came over and goes you
guys can't do this
and they said why you're brandon you're
bending my bars
he was bending me over
so so what's your max what's your match
probably in the sevens
are you serious so wait why is why is
squat weird for you then
just i'm talking about oh the taller the
hardest squat is the biggest i don't
think you worked on it either right
[ __ ] yeah yeah i see you for sure okay
an nfl first i mean squat was super
important yeah
yeah but but what do you squat yeah well
yeah what'd you get some legs who's
squad
well when i when i when i do i set up
any nights
i listen to him i just had to we'll get
you motivated well but jacob willick is
almost my age i don't know he's 50 maybe
i don't know what he is yeah and and uh
different though yeah a lot different
than me jaco could talk me to killing
somebody
yeah he's awesome he's awesome i never
met him but i love him but he was
having a very intense conversation about
whether or not
with his buddy echo whether or not uh
they go
that you go deep though you go deep he
goes now i go to the chair and you'll
see and i squat
and i'm like dude we in high school
right now what's going on
and you got to go deep did you did you
when you were out in texas did you see
tim kennedy at all
another guy who talked me into killing
somebody yes so so so when i was there
his buddy i think it's randy who is
in a lot of the pictures with him if you
see two guys tim
and a guy on it who they have the shirts
off they're both set up they're really
wide and thick
that would be his buddy i think it's oh
god is it
no they're just popping up with couture
no it's not randy it's uh
shane maybe maybe shane great guy so he
shows up in a helicopter with alex jones
who
i alex jones driving the helicopter uh
alex jones was up was in the helicopter
and they landed
in the street outside the studio kind of
illegally got out
alex jones had a long talk with him
interesting very nice
at the airport uh no at the at the
studio
what'd you guys talk about um there he
is there that guy right there
that guy right there yeah now his he
used to be a country
music guy and now he i think he owns a
lot of property he's like a big property
owner in austin
and he's real close to tim and i got a
textbook apocalypto here
i got a text from tim as i got on the
plane saying if you ever come to my
state again
and you don't call me i'm going to beat
your funny
witty head i was in dallas
and he loved him yeah thumbs down and i
said but if i
do i will these things are [ __ ] huge
yeah tim kennedy do you know who tim
is no special forces oh fighter
champion and i heard not from tim but
through the through the
grapevine that jocko and tim rolled they
did a little jiu jitsu together
i see him right there tim and uh all
respected he's pretty tall
no no no he's no tim is about five
maybe five nine not an ounce of
but it's interesting because people like
jack wasn't a gorilla on the mat and
kill her but
but you know from what i understood too
and this isn't he went toe to toe with
jockery yeah
so tim is going to beat him we got to be
cool tim's going to beat you in
yeah no matter who who's still training
jiu jitsu i i
i live jiu jitsu dude yeah no but i do
do a little jiu jitsu
look at tim's legs [ __ ] calves no tim
he's made for killing people tim is as
thick a human being as it gets
do you guys like your freedom you like
like be like have an opinion your
freedom yeah
thank him yeah thank him you're welcome
tim fights
he's so he's so he was special forces he
was arguably i'd say arguably
top three 185 are in the world for the
longest time
i mean beat basically beat you all
romero or certainly to a draw
and then it went i mean he's fought
everybody was struck was a strikeforce
champion
i mean a monster a monster always always
the guy you didn't want to fight
and oh by the way oh by the way also
while being a ufc contender was also
a special ops guy like an active
specialist still a green beret retired
retired from the ufc and still
he would just disappear like me and
brennan oh like i could text him right
now like i text him the other day
uh talking about something with politics
and he answered the question i was like
all right dude gotta go
and it's like he doesn't show me where
he's at but shows me a picture in his
uniform
with this like special badge on you can
tell he's like
in a helicopter yes i can hit over a
desert
like over a jungle i think i called him
i called him the other day and he goes
he answered the phone like this he goes
america
america how great is that guy he's
interested
in austin also a great guy but also like
a silly goose oh yeah like
super funny like we love brent and i
when we did a podcast with him
like a couple of school kids we got in
the car and and we went and brennan goes
is he the greatest guy in the world is
that my imagination cause he's
he's he's the best he's the best he's
just a great guy
yep i hope to meet this dude yeah if we
get
if we go to austin you will dude that
was before i was either uh
look at your yo yeah you look like you
look great yeah
what's going on there i've been dyeing
my beard
you look
but i'm going back to that because
that's a [ __ ] good looking guy right
he's a great looking dude
for hims.com promo coach so if you want
to look like brian there
poor hands forehand oh my gosh
what is he doing right there on top of
the table he's about to attack brian i
think yeah oh [ __ ]
yeah and i'm all for it hey look at that
look at that
yes well that was the day brennan cried
yep yeah but i have a theory with that
because we did dmt
i did i think that's exactly that's what
we did like that brandon started bawling
did you do it too i sure did yeah it's
fantastic
i could not stop we were taken through a
ceremony we were taken to a ceremony
with a shaman
by the name of audrey i saw him by the
way you did how is he i was in san
marcos he's doing great i miss him he's
doing great we're in san marcos that's
what's he doing just hanging out being
fabulous with a is he wearing like
he's married beads he's married now
married he's married oh the guy
so love aubrey right there's his wife
they dated before
broke up he did his thing uh tried being
uh polygamist you know do all that thing
and then got married and she's a smoke
show spectacular well so that's his wife
and he's winning and so
you'll love this he comes to the green
room and he's with justin wren and
justin wren had just found out
one of his friends uh close friends
kid committed suicide so justin comes in
just got done balling face is all red
the
the vibes in the green room with death
and we're talking about ct we're talking
about a friend who i'll tell you about
after
we're talking about horrible stuff and
like all right shop you're on in ten i'm
like
hey turn around go don't ever come to a
show again
don't ever come to the show with this
energy again oh my [ __ ] god
that's like when aubrey was laughing so
hard i'm like you can't no you can't i
gotta go make them laugh yeah it was
like right before the show
i had to do i had to do jennifer garner
brought me on stage
because i was doing i was emceeing i was
auctioning off
uh certain paraphernalia to raise money
for two children that have a very rare
genetic disease two little girls that
are gonna die
yes and dad gets up he can barely hold
together
mom gets up she can't hold it together
and then jennifer garner goes and now
brian
and i was live bro you got to get them
laughing you got to get them laughing
i i was i had a [ __ ] basketball in my
throat i'm like
oh here goes comedy dude i can't handle
that [ __ ] i can't handle it
pulled it off
were they quiet because they're artists
have a finger out though
that's the hood that's the thing oh that
is
[Laughter]
is called two creepy white guys so go
ahead okay no it's called two white guys
trying to be black oh hell yeah dude
ryan you're thinking that's gross
it's like this guy's why all fingers is
doing this guy okay
why are you making that noise
when i get off stage with the laugh
actually right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what this front of a bunch of other
comics i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song